dozens of veterans are in limbo tonight
as the future of their low income
complex is really unclear the landlord
of share village abandoned the property
last month christian casadas joining us
now in studio with an update on this
story christian well denise i spoke to
one veteran resident from the complex
today who says she is very concerned
over her future as well as the rest of
the community if the complex shuts down
gloria smith has been living at share
village since the beginning of august
after claiming that the complex website
was very attractive but she says the
unit was not what was promised and
claims she got a mrsa infection from the
filth smith paid three thousand dollars
to move in but last month she was
notified by a letter that the landlord
got coveted 19 and the program and
property would transition to the owner
ysbm investments llc that transition
smith says never happened and now the
future of vulnerable veterans is grim
these are vietnam veterans you know
they've defended our country
you know they're not criminals these are
these are elderly people that need our
help we have to take care of them we
reached out to arnold stock who is the
landlord of the property on las vegas
boulevard he told me he is still
seriously ill with covet 19 long hauler
symptoms
we just learned clark county district
court denied the petition to appoint a
new management company ysbm investments
is the leaseholder and they say they're
confident ysbm will begin to care for
the tenants as well as the property
christian casadas 8 news now